les milliers de pompiers on vous faire
tout ce qu'ils peuvent
la météo ne leur laissent bien peu de
répit dans la région de los angeles les
vents de santana se lève propulsant les
flammes avec une force presque
comparable à celle d'un ouragan au nord
de san francisco le plus grand feu dans
l'état le feu kincaid menace toute une
région réputée pour ses vins certains
vignobles pas résisté s'il ne reste
qu'une façade des tonnes de débris et
des rêves anéanti oui celui au travail
qui me rit mais quand tu nous tiens le
coup pour l'instant ça fait depuis
dimanche qu'elle et évacuer la fumée est
la respire chaque automne depuis trois
ans c'est la troisième fois donc je
crois qu'il ya certaines personnes qui
commencent à se poser des questions très
sérieuses savoir si on reste dans la
région se demander où on pourrait aller
c'est c'est vrai que c'est comme ça
chaque année ce n'est pas vivable
kimberley est allé se réfugier chez des
amis où l'électricité a été coupée par
mesure préventive pour empêcher la
propagation des flammes
quand tu coupe l'électricité comme ça il
n'est plus rien au dessus du tu peux pas
te réveilles ravitailler tu peux pas
chin a pas d'eau tu tu n'as pas
d'essence tu sais pas où tu veux aller
parfois tu n'as pas la communication
parce que les tours de de téléphone ne
marche plus donc c'est oui c'est un peu
comme le serment les traces des feux des
dernières années sont encore bien
visibles un peu partout dans la région
ici tout a brûlé il ya deux ans les
travailleurs ont commencé à reconstruire
ce quartier mais il est de nouveau
menacé la maison inhabitée avant les
feux et celle ci bruno rémy a choisi
dire bâtir sa maison même s'il a reçu un
ordre d'évacuation des autorités
il ne bouge pas il préfère attendre à la
dernière minute on comprend le risque
mais on a d'autres voisins qui ont pris
la même décision en disant nous on a été
là là derrière froid on veut protéger
nos maisons à un voisin qui avait
préparé
de la rosa et c'est le mien était aussi
déroulé au cas où peut-être pouvoir être
pouvoir sauver la maison comme beaucoup
de gens ici bruno adore la région il n'a
pas le goût de la quitter même s'il faut
souvent y vivre à ses risques et périls
ici l'heure incertain radio canada dans
la région de santa rosa